creo que todos tenemos una idea de que
estos préstamos de día de pago no son
muy buena idea aunque quizás sea un
último recurso para aquellas personas
que necesitan con urgencia el dinero ya
que estos préstamos cobran un interés
muy muy grande lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es explicar que son pero
también hacer algunos cálculos
matemáticos para comprender realmente
qué tan malos son estos préstamos en
términos de los intereses que generan la
forma en que estos préstamos funcionan
es que digamos que yo necesito
urgentemente comprarle un regalo a mi
esposo y quiero darle un regalo lujos
digamos que su cumpleaños es mañana y
quiero conseguirle un regalo costoso por
lo que necesito pedir prestado 500
dólares así que quiero tomar prestados
500 dólares
aunque yo sospecho que la mayoría de las
personas que requieren esos préstamos no
van a ser para comprar regalos y mucho
menos regalos caros seguramente están
desesperados por pagar la renta o para
comprar medicinas o comida pero por
cualquiera que sea la razón se necesita
tomar prestados 500 dólares y yo
sospecho que quien tiene que hacer este
préstamo realmente no tiene nada
guardado en su cuenta de banco entonces
digamos que voy con el prestamista y me
dice bueno está bien te voy a prestar
este dinero y no me voy a preocupar en
averiguar qué tan bueno es tu historial
crediticio para prestarte lo que quieres
vamos a necesitar tres cosas queremos
ver tu talón de pago es ver tu talón de
pago y conocer la fecha en la que te
pagan
y también quieren ver mi estado de
cuenta bancaria a que quieren ver estás
y la razón por la que quieren conocer
toda esta información es porque quieren
saber que aunque quizá mi historial
crediticio es terrible ellos van a
recibir lo que me prestaron más los
intereses imaginemos que yo voy a
recibir mi pago de mi empleador dentro
de dos semanas así que ellos podrán
cobrar lo que me prestaron en esa fecha
y para asegurarse de esto ellos tienen
que ver que yo realmente tenga un
trabajo este empleada y ver cuánto gano
y ver qué alcance lo que yo gano para
pagarles lo que me van a prestar y
digamos que me pagan mil quinientos
dólares cada dos semanas
también quieres saber cuál es el día de
pago y vamos a decir que el día de pago
es dos semanas a partir de hoy
y también quieren ver mi estado de
cuenta bancario porque este va a
mostrarles cuál es mi comportamiento de
gastos por ejemplo si recibo mi quincena
y ese dinero me lo gasto inmediatamente
en pagar la renta en comprar comida en
pagar mis impuestos hasta que llegue a
ser y cuando me vuelven a pagar pues
vuelvo a tener esta cantidad así que
esto les dice qué hago yo con este
salario periódicamente así que ellos me
dicen bueno le voy a prestar estos 500
dólares hoy pero lo que queremos que
hagas es que nos escribas un cheque y en
ese cheque que de hecho voy a dibujar
más o menos
y en ese cheque queremos que nos pagues
no quinientos dólares sino que por cada
100 dólares que te prestemos
por cada 100 dólares tú nos vas a pagar
25 dólares adicionales 25 dólares extra
y al principio yo podría decir bueno
pues no está tan mal una tasa de interés
del 25 por ciento quizá esté un poco
alta comparada con los intereses de
algunas tarjetas de crédito pero tomen
en cuenta que este no es un 25 por
ciento anual ese es un 25% cada dos
semanas al final de este vídeo vamos a
hacer algunas cuentas para ver realmente
cuál es la tasa de interés anual de un
préstamo de este estilo veremos cuál es
la tasa de interés anual efectiva en
este caso y estos datos no crean que son
inventados son realmente bastante
típicos para este tipo de préstamo así
que si me están prestando 500 dólares yo
tengo que devolverles los 500 dólares
dentro de dos semanas más 25 dólares
extra por cada 100 que me prestaron así
que me prestan 500 dólares más 25 por 5
serán 125 que sumados a los 500 dólares
que me prestaron será un total de 625
dólares pero como obviamente no tengo
este dinero porque si lo tuviera pues no
tendría que pedir este préstamo voy a
tener que postre
este cheque no voy a poner la fecha de
hoy así que digamos que ahorita es el
primero del mes de enero pero y digamos
que me van a pagar dentro de dos semanas
así que me van a pagar el 16 de enero
así que en lugar de escribir la fecha en
el cheque del primero de enero que es la
fecha en que lo estoy escribiendo lo voy
a post fechar para el 16 de enero que es
el día en que me pagan así que es 16 de
enero del año en el que esté así que
esto va a ser válido dentro de dos
semanas
así que dos semanas
en el futuro y bueno escribo lo demás
informado y bueno escribo la demás
información del cheque como que es para
pagar un préstamo de día de pago más
información del cheque como escribir la
cantidad con letra 625 aunque no me
tardó tanto en escribirlo para ahorrar
tiempo mi firma aquí un garabato
entonces yo les doy este cheque a estas
personas y ellas me prestan los 500
dólares y me dicen mira este cheque no
lo vamos a cobrar hasta que llegue la
fecha que notas tener que y cuando
llegue la fecha de pago tengo dos
opciones una es presentarme con las
personas que me prestaron el dinero
devolverlas en efectivo esta cantidad
que me prestaron más los intereses y
ellos me tienen que devolver este cheque
y ya pues yo lo destruyó la otra opción
es que no me presenté deje que esto pase
y esas personas lo que van a ser justo
en ese día van a ir a cobrar el cheque
así que si es que yo no les mentí estas
personas van a cobrar este cheque estos
625 dólares aplicando o cobrando este
cheque
y bueno si ustedes lo contemplan de
cierta manera es riesgoso para ellos el
haberme prestado el dinero ya que no
investigaron mi historial crediticio no
saben si yo tengo demasiados deudas o
qué pasa conmigo en esta cuestión así
que ellos en cuanto ven que llega la
fecha del día del pago inmediatamente
cobran este cheque pues para asegurarse
de recibir el dinero que me prestaron
más los intereses y hacen esto para
asegurarse de ser los primeros en cobrar
el cheque en cuanto me paguen sin
importar si a mí todavía me falta pagar
mi renta o mi comida u otras cosas así
que esta es la idea general sobre cómo
funciona este tipo de préstamos ahora
comenzamos diciendo que esto
probablemente no era buena idea de hacer
y ustedes se dan cuenta de esto ya que
están viendo que están pagando un
interés del 25% por cada dos semanas del
préstamo no por cada año veamos esto qué
significa con base en una tasa de
interés anual así que estamos pagando 25
dólares por cada 100 dólares así que son
25% un ciento son 100
así que literalmente significa 25% por
cada siento que esta es una interés del
25 por ciento 25 por ciento
de interés
por dos semanas
así que si fuéramos a calcular una tasa
de interés anual sencilla y que sea
ustedes quieran ver el vídeo sobre este
tema para comprenderlo un poco mejor
esto nos toma nuestro 25% y se
multiplica por el número de periodos en
el año si tenemos 52 semanas al año y
eso es cada dos semanas en lugar de
multiplicar esto por 52 vamos a
multiplicarlo por 26 ya que hay 26
periodos de dos semanas en el año así
que es 25 por 26 periodos de dos semanas
26 periodos de dos semanas por año
y cuando hacemos esta multiplicación
esto va a ser igual y vamos a sacar la
calculadora vamos a usar los números no
voy a usar los decimales 25 x 26
nos da 650 650 por ciento estamos
pagando una tasa de interés anual del
seiscientos cincuenta por ciento
así que si ustedes pensaban que las
tarjetas de crédito les cobraban muchos
intereses como quizás a una tasa del 25%
de interés anual
esto es 650 por ciento está muy por
encima de lo que cualquier tarjeta de
crédito podría cobrar de intereses está
realmente es una tasa de interés anual
tremendamente loca y esa es una tasa de
interés anual simple solo lo
multiplicamos por 26 esta no es la tasa
de interés anual efectiva o la tasa de
interés anual correcta matemáticamente
para hacer eso lo que tendríamos que
hacer y les recomiendo que vean el vídeo
correspondiente si dejaremos que este
fuera un interés compuesto imagínense
que si ustedes fueran el que presta el
dinero tendrían un interés compuesto ya
que agregarían el interés acumulado de
la cantidad prestada cada que pase el
periodo en el que aplicar esta tasa
para calcular la tasa de interés anual
efectiva
tenemos que tener 1.25 el 25 por ciento
más uno elevado a la potencia 26 ya que
tenemos 26 de estos periodos al año y
esto a que va a ser igual lo escribimos
en la calculadora 1.25 elevado a la 26 y
nos da este número tremendo vamos a
quitar un 1 de este no es que le vaya a
afectar mucho a la cantidad final esto
es 329 veces nuestro dinero así que este
1 de aquí sería un 100 por ciento es un
número tan grande que es difícil de
memorizar y tampoco es que nos dejen
hacer el interés compuesto de esta
manera así que este resultado podría no
ser tan acertado pero imaginando que ese
es el resultado correcto se va a tener
329 multiplicado por el dinero si lo
queremos escribir como porcentaje nos va
a quedar 32 mil 987 por ciento
o sea que después de un año se tendrá
que pagar aproximadamente 330 veces el
dinero que nos prestaron obviamente no
nos dejan tener el interés compuesto de
esta manera pero esto les da una idea de
lo ridícula que es esta tasa de interés
quizás ustedes hayan escuchado el
término usura en el pasado la usura
significaba cualquier tipo de interés
pero ahora en nuestro contexto cultural
se asocia la palabra usura con un nivel
de interés irracional quizás este límite
sea diferente para diferentes personas
algunas personas pueden decir que es
irracional pagar el 25 por ciento de
interés anual o del 30 por ciento de
interés anual o el 40 por ciento de
interés anual pero yo creo que todos
estaríamos de acuerdo que el 650 por
ciento o el 33 mil por ciento de interés
estas son tasas irracionales y
definitivamente son usura así que
ustedes procuren evitar esto a toda
costa sólo si su vida dependiera de ello
es que podrían aceptar ese tipo de
préstamos